movies aren't always designed to be easy
to understand sometimes it's your own
fault for not paying more attention but
there are also times when the entire
audience just doesn't get it
here are a few scenes that need it a
little bit of extra explaining Donnie
Darko fact nobody understood Donnie
Darko the first time around
especially the insane ending it's
complicated but Donnie send the
free-falling jet engine back in time to
kill himself and thus save the world
because well alternate reality time
travel stuff it's all explained in the
director's cut but some viewers believe
that Donnie didn't actually have to die
to save the world
and that's sending the jet engine
through time was enough death isn't
inevitable but Donnie knows what is
going to happen he lets himself die
because he feels at peace by the time
all of his alternate universe
time-travel shenanigans are over one
miss with the universe or not that bunny
was still pretty freaky Star Trek during
the climax of JJ Abrams Star Trek Spock
ignites a black hole inside the villains
ship and this scene plays out ship is
compromised so close to the singularity
to survive without assistance which we
are willing to provide
captain what are you doing you show them
compassion maybe the only way to herpes
from the romulus it's logic Spock but
you'd like that I'm not really confused
viewers had to wonder is Spock giving in
to human emotions those bad guys had
previously destroyed Spock's homeworld
and killed his family after all
but Spock's behavior is actually 100%
Vulcan early in the movie young Spock
learns the ethical concept of
supererogation
or as they define it when it is morally
praiseworthy but not morally obligatory
most viewers didn't remember the earlier
Vulcan school scene with that black hole
business pure Vulcan ethics fascinating
Total Recall Arnold Schwarzenegger plays
a man named Douglas Quaid who visits a
company to have artificial memories of a
secret-agent adventure implanted in this
brain but something goes wrong turns out
that Quaid is actually a sleeper agent
and the fake memory process starts to
reactivate his real memories or is that
just part of the imaginary adventure if
I'm with me who the hell am I director
Paul Verhoeven put the true answer in
the movie during the final shot Quaid
stands on the mountains of Mars and
there's a bright flash from the Sun so
the initial procedure actually did go
terribly wrong happy ending
nope it's a doctor cutting into a man's
wrecked brain I have a headache it might
be a tumor it's not a tumor American
Psycho Patrick Bateman is a man who
spends his nights committing
increasingly vile acts of violence he
motionlessly narrates his experiences
making statements like well I simply am
NOT
there eventually he calls his lawyer and
leaves a message confessing to his
crimes but when he confronts his lawyer
in person he doesn't even recognize
Bateman fans have debated whether or not
Dayton's murders are actually real but
according to director Mary Harman the
point of the lawyer scene isn't to cast
doubt on Batemans murders but to
emphasize that it doesn't matter
whatever Bateman is he's normal Wall
Street and the whole world is full of
self-involved Psychopaths
how's that for bleak lost in translation
an aging movie star named Bob meets
Charlotte a married woman and the two of
them connect deeply lost in translation
ends with them about to part ways
forever when Bob runs to find Charlotte
they hug and you whisper something in
her ear before leaving most assume that
this was a romantic ending but it was
meant to be heartbreaking and the
original script Bob tells Charlotte to
stay with her husband unable to tell her
that he loves her
honestly we preferred the mystery thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know what movie endings you'd
like to see explained